I did
dude
that's gross
I guess I'm done there
I should be able to go to the basement
now all right I'm glad oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
hi Daniel I don't know if this is a good
place to hide what am i doing
kappa new corner cap in the corner
[ __ ] I thought it was gonna get away you
see
don't come in here please don't come in
here
[ __ ] [ __ ] you he sounds weirder now it's
like he's pissed at me what I done
[ __ ] don't go in here please
get away
ah easy gun
this
hey there
oh I'm insane now god damn it
seriously
oh oh we got the creepy corridor left
uh-uh
bro
from
it's gonna run for it
oh great
back in the sewers huh
that was creepy I hate that guy
such a douche how I done
all right down here
junctions
let's bring this with us oh we can't sad
face
down in the sewers because why not
what oh I'm out of oil I have plenty of
tinderboxes up
ah this looks creepy
I get the feeling he's close
I must kind of fool Oh mushrooms
delicious
oh oh oh oh [ __ ] already
oh he's there I see you oh that's great
right [ __ ] awesome
oh this places
wonderful
Oh
it's here
Oh Oh don't shake on me
all right it's gonna go in here nothing
creepy about that
oh come on
whoa whoa whoa whoa
dude where's that coming from seriously
hate the cell
no way don't tell me the water Mall
series bike
sounded like him
ah
I come from here
Oh
oh thank god we need oil
awesome and a puzzle
so we've got to stuff with three
different
combination did we get any moment on
this
what does that do
what the hell
it's gonna try every combination
I'm confused
oh well
back in the water god damn it
oh nice
is this where he came from
oh [ __ ] I thought it was a water monster
ha
Oh what's up at this place I don't get
it
uh-huh
all right so we've got a pipe not sure
would we need that for Oh
what is that I don't get it
oh [ __ ]
all right Oh tenon bucks awesome
it's pretty well lit up for a sewer have
to say that
oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] thing scares me hold
it up
right
let's go here
try
I don't know what to do this here
uh-huh yeah that's gonna work
it's gotta be momento cookies sorry my
voice cracks the two levers control the
noisy machine
what
all right let's sit back here
goddamnit
mm-hmm
they're all right let didn't work
think I need to pass that Oh cutscene
oh really
Shai go in there not a good idea
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I thought I saw something
hmm
what am I supposed to do
there's got to be like some combination
that shuts up the machine
oh maybe I can jam the pipe in it
ah
spinning too fast
Papa put them in the lowest they put
them in the highest they're both in the
lowest
Oh bigger cogwheel means slower speed
does isn't it
Thanks
oh [ __ ]
this way
and now we should be able to know it's
still spinning fast
oh ah well well I'm confused
it didn't change anything I'm really
confused here maybe one should be big
and one should be small let's try that
[ __ ] I hate that you have to run so far
run man yo ray
and this
same speed right
let's try the other combination them
and it's not a lot of ideas
all right
oh it sounds really quiet now I should
have used that as a hint whoa no no no
no no no no no no what have I done
you see there
ah oh no don't come here for [ __ ] sake
ah I should have closed the door holy
[ __ ]
it looks like [ __ ] et
hey too